[Music]  well the raiders hit the news today that  general manager mike mayok is battling  the covet virus the 62 year old  released a short statement to the nfl  this afternoon it reads  very grateful that i am vaccinated as i  could very easily be in a hospital  rather than working comfortably from  home remember last year now at this time  john gruden contracted the covid virus  we certainly wish for a speedy recovery  for mayok as the season approaches now  raiders counting down the days until the  kickoff of course their  free three preseason games before they  march into the  regular season on september 13th a big  monday night game against the baltimore  ravens